[music
] welcome to the OMR podcast today a
guest was looking forward to you really really long
I saw the
various YouTube documentaries about him for the first time from
him that it
can't all be true what kind of things
drove the story lasts  by
saygin Yalcin from Bremen about the WHU
to Dubai just crazy
[music]
[applause]
Thank God text text text and
you put the compliance platform for
the digital economy so everything that
can be controlled the colleagues can
solve in particular
Cross-border
Gibson sells harvest maturity natural with the
problem of coming up and registering in
the target countries for
tax purposes under submitting tax returns
and so on. Sometimes traveling in several
countries becomes
complicated via text you give a
central contact text you
just do it then  for you and of
course also compatible with DATEV, the
well-known accounting software  goods can therefore process
10,000 20,000 50,000 more transactions
per month bloggers via text you am
or tax consultants will be
happy and the text you had in 1
simply then everything is easier there are of
course also interfaces to a
wide variety of marketplaces with someone who
works with Amazon or ebay understand the
ERP system  from plentyMarkets to central
or to the shopify Shopware shop system and
anyone who wants to
try it out now the first three months
will be free of charge as the basic package for
€89 a month would save you money
if you simply send a short email
to OMR Text du.com or die
Page looks at Text du.com and then collects
when contacting us on the pot
Note
[music]
Note on our partner phalcon.
So faking like the bird in English
the falcon the plane written with C
AIO
everyone knows that is a social
media suite that can really cover
everything posting about it of course
terminating the post that you do yourself
is also meant to hear so listening
what is on the net  one is told you
also have monitoring all the tools and
features you need by 8 p.m. to
be completely mastered again are in there
at Falkenau
meanwhile 30005 how the use
has been on the market for ten years belongs to
the Tyrion family also
virtuis trendwatch and has it  Of course,
huge partnerships with all the
relevant platforms from
Facebook Twitter Instagram and so on are
always part of falcons.  Eggs
actually means
half of course half I want to tell
you a bit about Bremen that was for
you now the beginnings were
not so easy what you can read about it that
was a really
difficult childhood there are still
pictures on the internet if you can see  where you
grew up there are also quite
a few dead here dead injured you
lying on your doorstep in your neighborhood and stuff like that
don't know that he has ok megaclinic
childhood as a good childhood when I look
back my parents
made sure that I was bitten by their
stories  was shielded the
bad was not the case but
where I actually had the liters of sun that
my sister was very ill
I noticed that within the first 6 months of her
life when I was eight
she was six months old when she had epileptic for the
first time
I got a fit and that was the first thing I
noticed before my
parents saw it, and then she was
blue  started, I saw her in the
kitchen, then she was still sliding, a little
baby, and then she was
in the hospital for several years, so it's
not like that for a few days now and
I also noticed how my mother
then went from being a
lawyer to a housewife and then
since then  every day for the last 28
years then only taking care of them
and my father wasn't in Germany at all
he was a veterinarian in the first two
years of my life he did his
doctorate in Turkey then
two years later he was only allowed to go to Germany
and not work there  as a
veterinarian you then have to
go cleaning in factories that taught me a lot
that firstly I
saw how my parents dealt with such a
situation
you study your whole life
team it's like finally
building up a small civil service and
then you can't work  my
mother because of my
sister's illness and my father because he was
n't allowed to work here and so on  l had to
try it is like an
approbation that you have to do and then
in the meantime you already have two
children and then maybe have to make do with 1000
marks
I still had a good childhood
I didn’t need a lot of money back
then and got into football very early on
concentrated because I thought
my childish head, if I get
rich now as a professional soccer player, then
I could simply buy the best doctors
and then heal my sister through it,
we think everything will be new again, just think
, if you have a child, then you are A-Junior Bundesliga,
played at Bremen in  Bremen yes so
will but always no that was Union 60
partner club madness league and have
but relatively at some point I was
already in Tini then noticed that it is
very unlikely that you
will still be very rich with it yes like in
the 500 best football players worldwide
are you maybe earn a few
million 500 best entrepreneurs in the world
are you multimi  billionaire
I recognized that relatively early yes I
didn't really want to become a
multi-billionaire I was
looking for a way to
earn a lot of money yes it's still with
this childish thought I can
then solve this problem it
just won't go away
what did I do I said
maybe
football he not I'm going to
study medicine now so that I can become a
doctor because doctors will be
enough he said which doctors the
cosmetic surgeon then I wanted to become a
cosmetic surgeon but at 19 he
has 18 18 I think yes  I then
worked in the hospital in
plastic surgery, you have to do it,
so you can't
study medicine without this internship,
good school leaving certificate, that's not enough,
you still have to do an internship in the
hospital and then you can first
study medicine, I did where  you
then really fired Erwitte Samsara
gifted you also got a 1.  0 Abitur or
good
Abitur I did very well in 2001,
but
it was actually
more about the fact that I
wanted
to be a doctor now and my sister could help in turn,
but I could also become a
cosmetic surgeon and then have this
glamorous life and then I
also went to the library  I asked the
librarian please don't give me
all the books by German
cosmetic surgeons to
read yes I just wanted to
know who the real ones called then
I called the
Bodenseeklinik your one
called Cologne then said what can
I do  talk to the doctor why
because it's at stake for my life i need to
know what i'm supposed to be how much
earn the old one
then really get an appointment
that was because i also think the
assistant then noticed that
i sounded a bit desperate
then said it's really about
should I study medicine or not
and  only then I was told very clearly
don't do it because of the money it won't be that
great and right
away you have to be able
to become a good doctor at all, not just with this thought behind it
, I heard that
but ignored him then he still did an
internship there  I was then
fired because the nurse had also
said you medicine no so
you could become an
entrepreneur and I
really only played Playstation all day long made
bread coffee and got on
very well with the patient
but when it came to the matter
at  OP is to be there or something like that
I was never able to see blood and
things like that and it was a lot of misery yes
yes and that was
food for thought for me and to say ok that's
actually not so bad that
I've been through everything I did
Yes, I was unconsciously on the journey
to my passion and
I think that is the first step to
really  to try and when a
lot of young people ask me, how did you come up with the idea of
ng an entrepreneur or ho
did you manage this and that or am
I already too old and I say
if you are in your 20s, 30s,
ou are even in your
0s  not too old most successful
companies in the world are founded by
45-year-olds top 1% of the big
startups
that means
if you are listening now you are 20 and 30
so you are not too old you are
still on the journey to
or in search of  so your
passion is soccer
cosmetic surgeon entrepreneur that's how it was
for me was also
a DJ for eleven years in the meantime so that's why a
Bremen evening during my
school days and also the university time I
've only been with her for three years and
with Supertalent 3  Played for years near
Cologne then studied others but then came over
every weekend because he was
overdue to do some research and
seen here, too, this is the best
economy  suni Germany after the same way
I noticed it so it was
my fault fellow students then
said hey I was at this
I don't think it was a trade fair here in Hamburg
even and the universities introduced themselves
a bit is good and says hey that
's probably the best  Business School
Germany I just wanted to tell you
don't even try it
you can't make it
that's very cool thanks for the tip I'll
try it it's like that I do
n't know if I'm still like
this you can only apply once in a lifetime
It's really hard but I had
a lot of extracurricular activities
that I think also helped
and as I said I was a DJ I was a
soccer player I
would like to be a cosmetic surgeon I
really tried out a lot of facets of life
yes I think that
's still in trend today  to my
businesses that we really try a lot of things
because that's the only way to find
the best things that surprise
Duden re ur arrived and was that
a normal one for you, that was
unusual, yes, it doesn’t matter then that too I
had baggy trousers and a huge Elmo
T-shirt, I can remember it again
, just so oversized XXL and
then it was a lot  with light blue
shirt correct i don't know anything either that so
i thought it was because they
all have these polo shirts and shirts
right now and all other [ __ ] goods but
in the end i really met my
favorite people there who
i would be looking back at now that you her
I'm sure you've had a lot of guests from there there are really smart boys and girls there but that's coming that's really coming if I look back now and say hey what
did vero teach you then
I would say clearly the basics of
entrepreneurship or corporate management in
general but the most important thing is believe
I met these people for life and how
we motivated each other but of
course I was also at the
beginning  a little bit
so
special there I didn't look like
the rest and there weren't many
who had my background
maybe that's a good thing because I got to
know a new perspective
we all have one thing in common I
think we had this drive
really under high pressure
to deliver selective
basic studies x 120 written exams
that was very exhausting and that
taught me this learning
no
then it was finished and then you went
to Dubai did you do any
internships what you then about  McKinsey
meanwhile it's really
ABC again, but these big names
or that's what this consulting does,
I also looked at it, I was
at Capgemini and at BMW and at Loreal,
so I also
looked at trailers, I looked at consultancy
but what me  really
appealed then
entrepreneurship don't take it
away that he doesn't keep coming back  he worked with someone else after somewhere in
wardam you founded it yourself but
not in any way as you can see so
right after university after the Diploma Ball
I went to the DJ World Tournament
that was what I just wanted to
enjoy my life for a bit and I did
then total heels half a year or almost
never yes then hung up all over the world
that I was from Hawaii and the USA and was
traveling with my friends I said
it was going to start soon so
let’s have fun again
I did that and then I did  back then
this business model was maybe someone
else that means
they brandsforfriends hartgeld.com and
all these shoppers reifen2go these
shopping clubs which were then very
successful 2008 9 the times 2010 and
I thought ey ey these shops are the
right ones  Yes, trendsetters
did sell brands, but
they also created brands and made them
relevant because when you were there
was listed where you were then
sold thousands of times relatively quickly, although you
really weren’t that well-known
and what I then realized, ok,
why don’t I become a supplier of
this shopping club then
accordingly founded 1 2 brands
handbags for women
and diamond and gold rings  and I thought to
myself, I'll get a brand
specifically designed for the cost structure of the
shopping
clubs.
Yes, and then I got an investment of 20,000 euros
from two business angels
. That's how it started and then I said,
like now, I'll just get the
best leather handbags for women
Of course I had no idea about it
because my girlfriend asked at the time hey
can you help me somehow to design then I made my
own designs then
until okay now I just give it
to the factory in Italy and then they
produce it and then it goes to
the  Shopping clubs so easy this
presented to me I'm about some
relationship  I then found out
where a well-known Italian brand also
produces
and elfenfabrik sent my designs
said I would like to
produce here and they then said he
said that's right
no so we don't do the designs are really not
professional I said yes fine
then do it yourself
and they think we can do it
with an order quantities there was sometimes he
has to at least buy something because I
said yes I can’t buy that much now
but make a sample and
if I like it then order it  me
more and this sample is of course
also very expensive, you ca
n't sell it profitably and in retrospect
I can't afford the price with a discount
either who is definitely
not geared towards the cost structure of the
shopping clubs, yes, but
they just have such brilliant ones  samples made
yes really that was such a good bag
that I then had I then
for this first  e sample
episode, yes, I think
I paid too much for eleven or twelve designs,
but that was okay because
now I had really good samples that I
could send to China.
That was my idea, yes,
which country is really good for
leather handbags  or generally wrong
Italy yes for creating but for
copying China just extremely good yes
I then have this website everywhere back then
what was Alibaba there was Globus Zurich
that existed yes I then found your
factory Infusion that is not even in the village
in China  somehow
Beijing or something like that or not at all
I really flew there so
I wrote some details and that's why I yes I have samples here
you can make them bags must
n't cost more than 20 €
or 30 € somehow the design depends
on it  like so yes we can do
it first sent him the pictures
yes we can copy them and then they sent
me something back and d  as he looks so
bad I said call I
'll come again then flew over to
have a look at the factory and then
also got to know the chat that means yes
then everyone with
Jack meant here that our factory is
here the people do it for you yes
we  try again then
use 2-3 iterations then they can
really produce these Italian bags one-to-one
these other great selection but 90%
cheaper like that and I made the
first collection from them and then
I was able to make 1200 bags
then I sent them to the
shopping clubs because there
were a few that were founded by Verona
and the first collection
sold out immediately for 18 hours yes and then
that was canceled for me then the drive
was like that I love business yes
you just have to  just find your way
here you can see yours too yes Italian
luxury brand I couldn't have
afforded I can't buy a bag for 50  Sell 0 € nobod
knows the brand but for 8
€ yes and that sounds like a disco
nt because the real price pond
99 for me but at Shopping Club
ounds 80 and I controls him still make
profit yes my flashlight costs
20-30 euros  so I was able to
generate a nice scam I
sold the collection but then I
already talked to other business angels
relatively well-known business angels
maybe everyone knows dad Klaus
hommels Ali young back then only in one of
my early mentor so very, very,
very much a really I would  already
say my idols were there
then I talked to them early in the morning and then we
considered whether we shouldn't do a shopping club
ourselves yes we then
analyzed the markets and said here they are
everywhere they already existed there
in Turkey there were in  Russia
Germany USA
but somehow to the east there was
n't one then yes I flew to Dubai
backpack
2009 I now have a restau
rant put in said I now
know roughly what the cost structure of the
shopping club is, yes, and then I also know
what they pay attention to, what they
sell, I also received tips
because the shopping clubs are not
just your sales platform in some way
, they also give you tips  they
say everything that has no size
problem sells better, e.g.  Pants because
at that time it was difficult to wear jeans, people
want to try them on and
overall you have no idea rings or bags
and things that anyone can buy
without knowing these sizes and with these
tips and at the time also with the analysis
of the shopping club in France that
was the biggest bonprix we should
we analyzed that said hey i
need my business plan here in
dubai sat
in the restaurant for free free wifi canceled a salad
just order coke cool i
'm building here now i'm talking to the
business angels here with the
potential investors  Investors and also with the
potential team and
then I sat there
for six months and worked on it, and in the meantime
I was able to convince investors because I
said I already had a team and
I didn't have the team yet but
I didn't have any data  many
failures were flown in because I
said that you are also good at
Unity  is the opportunity to really
build up e-commerce in the Middle East he
just has to introduce you to the fashion sector
we have 300 million
people in the Middle East but somehow we have
maybe a handful of
e-commerce companies that are really
good was a huge opportunity
these people said  will
not only hang around online on such media
or read news they will
also make transactions at some point and that was
the bet
then we
are there then I was
able to convince the team when the term sheet was there
too where they said ok we
only had  Idris in Dubai Shopping Club that
was that is sugar sugar in
Arabic means sugar okay yes that was then the
belief in Israel so that among other
things we also had
those who were there
directly through Tiger global yes that was
really Indesit Round Tiger
global was there  that was extreme that was in
2009 and early 2010 we got
$1.9 million silver round for funds
is
2009/2010 that's great he
has a good team so we were able to convince a lot of people
to move to
Dubai he has to introduce you to tech
talent just wasn't that common back
then just didn't want many
companies to need it
that you need  grew very big relatively quickly
we somehow
already made a million dollars in sales in the 7th month
Pomona then increased relatively quickly to 250 employees
then also worked in
Zierikzee and she wants to be
and then I needed more money yes
I then said the  Medium is what it
is and business angels are no
longer enough let's somehow and I'm
talking about like I said from a
decade ago the numbers were different
let's raise something like 20 30 million dollars
and then I flew to South Africa to
a big company  Nerve history
inventor billions
just sat with them and said
what but wrote more hey I'm
from Dubai okay I already have  n got an
info yes I got an intro
I also had good investors so
the guys I just mentioned
are already injured be
going there soon I'll try to convince you they
said then
somehow the round is for us  still too
small as I said ok I do
n't need more money now and the idea came
up right away said ok we have
another company in the Middle East
that has an ebay model
that it is Zug
and the idea was ok we are
now we  we have now set up warehouses
we have our own logistics we
have we have this picking and
packing conscience actually how to do
e-commerce and that ebay
model they were pretty well known for they
had a lot of traffic
but they only had fish the a
lot of traffic  a lot of products but
no retail also has exactly we had
exactly this missing piece said
why don't we pack it together
and we this belongs
I heard Jabbar Internet group
is that your place in Dubai like you
operator and said yes no let's
merge that that's the village and
then we started talking then
said hey we together
we would somehow have 400 500 employees
together  could really form the largest
e-commerce platforms in the Middle
East you have millions of visitors
and we have all the logistics, we
have products that also belong to
us, but we also set up an inventory model
at some point and that worked,
yes, and then we have the train  .com Group
I was then President of zu 41
President of the Schublok
comgroup then also became a partner of the Tchibo
Internet Group
and that of course became very
strong because then we abolished the auction
completely they said the
ebay model doesn't work let's get
out there now  Make an Amazon model because
now we have it yes yes we have it
Marketplace and we have retail the
h  First of all, we have products ourselves and
we have the list because the list came
from this ebay model, the
combination works very well, as I
said, 4,000 employees
then made
another 400 million dollar
investment through Nerf Buster, all of which made a significant
contribution
and that's how we ended up
founding the souq.com Group, which
later also joined our
son
[music]
, either make-or-buy, yes, and
we just thought about what's
the best solution to do against Amazon's
competition  it's not that much fun yes
at some point they will have
more money than us or we will always be more
valuable and
win-win-win yes
it was extremely good for the consumer when Amazon entered the
market we already had them
we already had everything ready yes  we were active in
four countries
in egypt saudi arabia in kuwait in
july we were the market leader amazon
naturally has worldwide world cl  ass
excellence built in what is still working at
Amazon than after she lives
and what I warn you I was still involved
but what I did is in
2013 I founded sellanycar
yes that sounded really
crazy too many of my partners because
I have  I said hey there are two types
of company-wide after selling
Amazon before that was before before the sale
was I was already president and and
so you still did in the
other yes I then
resigned as an active director but I’m
still a full shareholder  stayed because
i said to my partner hey i
have my passion by
saying to myself there are two types of
entrepreneurs one that
pulls these rough diamonds out of the mine and the
other one that makes jewels out there and
i just love that rough diamond
then into one  form where
the next manager
can make jewels outside and I just wanted to go back
into the mine  I
went in and then said I discovered a huge problem selling cars selling
used cars that
can be done online is a huge
time we are talking here today about a used car market
of more than 65 billion dollars in our countries alone I said yes the problem
in our countries is how
active it is
I would like to solve that you
can sell cars within 30 minutes
and the inspiration came from England
there was a company called webuyanycar
dacom they have the offer they
said here an old
used car dealer who then
discovered the internet at some point
said we buy  your cars in 30
minutes and then
bought them on inventory and then
sold them to an auction house nine days later the
auction house
bought them up later as they are called they can be
bought relatively cheaply and in
hindsight I have to say but that was a very,
very successful one  shop in
usa also as if i cardano in usa
there is kar  l-Werner yes they are
relatively big now but there
was K&K Werner only for eight
years karl-max had been around in
Germany for ages Kemal auto1 exactly they
were still very under the radar yes
they had yes he started them
started almost at the same time
yes I think they
didn't do any PR at all for two years
I think we did then it will be when
he adorns the founders of the company
no money right because the money or a
share when he hasn't been
paid that  here in the in
this group that made a bit of
money I had made a bit of
secondary but
I was able to set up the 90 was the
100 percent owner of sell
Annika also on my own then made
a lemon again with loqui
she is however it was for  me
then a bit easier so that
was really within a week
or so I could now I have a
lemon pulls I actually have
all  one made or preseed and then
came sees with the investors especially from
the region from the region one from the
region we are then for three
months we then tried somehow we buy
any car to build up the model
I noticed relatively quickly and
that was what happened  again simply through
the observation of my team members yes
I said so I will explain the
model online there
is a valuation for your car if
you agree more or less for the
benchmark then you come to one of our
fee Aalen and we inspect your  Car
again briefly and then we buy it and
these purchased cars then go to
dealers, yes, and the dealers
then somehow buy them from you later
, but the model is not quite
right because there is an inventory
risk, first of all, you didn't know
how much you are supposed to buy the car for
and secondly, it may be that you
somehow can't get rid of yourself and you do
n't have it  t mental risk and through the
salvation of my team, I noticed
that during the purchase, so
during the inspection
, they already called the dealer, so
the dealers said hey, how much,
how much should we buy, what
would you pay for it, and that what
about  We then built WhatsApp into
an auction house and that
was the first time, so we then had
something that we called live
auctions, which we then invented where
we built these buying and
selling procedures into a
15-minute process  That means
that while the customer is inspecting his car with us
and it is still in our
building, we have already listed the car
on an auction platform
that also belongs to us, so in the meantime
we have then merged two companies
and then we have identified the
highest bidder, then
ours  Magician deducted and then we were able
to offer it to the seller,
our partner vodafone has  a new
collaboration at the start and extremely
interesting Vodafone song we work also
rework the coworking company par excellence
that you know and how does the
cooperation work easily? Vodafone
Business offers what you already
know from Vodafone Business, namely Aldi
tools for hybrid modern work  of
innovative cloud solution of a
virtual telephone system security apps of
course in combination the best
mobile and fixed network tariffs and now
also after a partnership with
rework and as a Voda von Witten customer you get a
50% discount on all wework
locations worldwide there are over 700 pieces
that are happy to use  would like to
find out more at vodafone.de Slash new work
from the buyer it was mostly
when some people who say the cars were then
resold by an African in Arabia new are the
exporters then there are people who
then repair it and then go back to
their showrooms  pack and that's how it
developed that we
built up a huge portal of
dealers who are now bidding
and that made it so competitive that
the prices were relatively
attractive for the sellers and we
didn't need inventory yes and that's
our further development so we've
always had inspiration from other businesses
too but  then we became
our own version, which has
now been profitable for several years
how was still
the group today you have it too exactly you
already relatively so we are the
market leader by a wide margin so I can
tell you that about every
fifth  every tenth car so 10% is sold to
us in in in in our
countries Emily and Saudi
Arabia we are also running and we have
also registered over 35% of all cars with us
that is in the country at all
but there are numbers if  we think that was
kind of the
last round of financing
that jim w so the value of all the
cars over the bottles  trade
was then already more than 100 million
more I don't know what I what
what status you have but we are
definitely already more what I can tell
you about the financing round of sell any
car we didn't plan to do that recently
You actually made a deal two years ago,
but announced a year ago that the
government brought it in. Yes, that means
we should have the sovereign wealth fund
from Arabia ZBI PIF daughter sanabel invested
our last round for them
and of course they invested a
lot  helped financially but what was much more
important for me if the company
is profitable which was much more important
that we then had such a huge door opener
when Jessi is also there that is
basically the
one company that then gets money from 6 governments of dizisi
countries they then as
how they invest, they are also there,
that means we got this bum and got
Berking and that allowed us
in Saudi-Ara  Bien to expand relatively quickly
, so within
a year we have now hired 150 people
in 22 cities with 41 branches, yes, that has
grown extremely quickly with large
partnerships that we would otherwise not have managed so
quickly if we had
not noticed this branding from the government
is very important to me
how solid it started with the
company when was because since the founding of
enough 2000
12 I started working on it
2013 on with lounge and now everything means
78 years are you doing it now and after that
where are you  here
yes so it is still my baby
and my passion so
sellanycar is now a group of
different brake caliper workers
before your question or after your question
why
are we sitting in three digits so we already
hear three digits so it
makes exactly two every few hundred people
so once i i got what
i think after inside was smart i
got namely at  the first only a
small second bride wife made a
payment and then
most of the payment actually got in shares
in the group yes and
I left them there as well, which
Amazon later bought so
to some extent Köniz Events and authors
but not then economically so
that  you could have said with working under normal
conditions in Bremen that
what's the point now, not at all for me,
yes, I would
still work for you at 70 as I know myself,
yes, but my goal is
not necessarily to become rich now  in order to be
rich but I recognized at the
age of eight that I have a
very big problem that you can't
necessarily buy it but you can
indirectly ensure that my
sister leads a better life yes of
course she is financially
secure now there is no foundation  how
will her life after my life
still take care of them something like
a Kö  [ __ ] I founded it that's
for her but you don't need that much she'll be cared for pretty much
her whole
life if I shouldn't
be there or my parents and the rest
goes into medical research and into
entrepreneurship I'm investing a lot
now as an angel  and different
business models
the German billionaire Dubai will probably come straight away are
you thinking of writing something like
nonsense or is
that saying so much about it again? okay it’s
okay or do you say that I should write to you
, I’m not coming,
yes, the latter, but in the end, of course,
the films are very  worth a lot but
I I now have a billion in
the account
that's yes that
'll be known very quickly and then I get an
e-mail from the well-known business angel
and say hey you have to meet buddy here
and I should  can't i
don't have time or so
has he really been canceled any meeting every hour
that has to be so yeah he
's coming  from Saudi Arabia is
also in business as you are really
doing now so if you have time
I went there I
met him in the hotel lobby you mean
experienced older gentleman said yes if
I got this intro I am happy
how can I help so you are really
an inspiration that
you have built up in our region and I am also an
entrepreneur and
then I said very and what do you
do so he so yes I also have I
also have a car company and others so
what's your name  actually with last names
I googled by the way and he
then just told me that he z.b.
owns a well-known brand and so and
then I just read both of them if the
article was just he and his brother 60
billion dollars networld have the
assets or did I mean that to him ey
I'm really sorry I have I should
google your name beforehand  and how
can I help you so I would
like to be a partner with you or I
would I would like to take a
closer look at your company can
we not do it together I of
course only want to fly to my office
a week later and then how was it
then that was the dvali Brothers
Aldi they were for a while the
richest Arabs in the world but belongs to
Nissan and Mercedes and Audi among
others they are very very very
Federal Cross of Merit from Germany
by the way I
was at his house
seilwolff
totally in the palace very  very
modest and at these moments we keep saying
hey please don't show off in any
way or something like that is just
healthy  means then trying
to make a birthday present
somehow not like that so we already know each other
before she was also with me we are
talking about the basement so which
of the Kardashians
Kendall Jenner Candy was
at my house before Dubai we were that
not that we are strangers it's
her birthday and then I flew to her
birthday but
I had curtains put up on the street at both entrances
so that no one could see that
I was driving in there and behind the
curtains there were paparazzi that
means there are  actually no
proof that I was there but I
think there was someone there who
talked to the press that was
and nice because in the end it should
n't come out at all it was just
a birthday celebration and I mean
what do you have Auto
Wraith black  Badge nice
nice car I can you
superchefs
no Audi 1
so okay
understand something like that writes then they should
also get the right one  Auto write so it
wasn't just any
over 400,000
is
n't everything so
stupid at some point
so if you live in Dubai you see them
more often no they're all
booked there every week or,
as I said, they have some performances and
then you get to know them  about
friends and then if you, as I said,
if you know a few then
you will be recommended and say hey if you are
in Dubai you should
meet up and yes that
's a bit over the years the
ambassador of Dubai for  the
American thermal world you can say
yes or you can also
you can also say I used to have an
agency a concierge agency that
looked after
celebrities that was
there in Dubai I always had that on the side
and that’s why we built up such a
service landscape  and that
was good, they don't
come to me like that and we drink tea,
we also had a gnawing tour, they
then  did safaris or
buggy dune bagging entonces fun fun
so the team and then were
worth more but meanwhile
we are friends but if I now e.g.
you can go to Dubai somehow with the agency
but Marie
we don't have her anymore you don't have online
anymore but you're still
invited
[laughter]
[music]
I don't know no idea any
Philipp Philipp III
justin was there but I have  didn't meet him
forgiving
but was cared for exactly that was the
case but otherwise
no idea give me any names
I can think of something okay but as I said I'm not such a part-time
job
[laughter]
maybe vonvon.me should be Richard
Branson or something like that  so many people
follow yes and that was a conscious
decision i was 5 + 5 years
ago i started 56 years and before
that i was really under the radar i
didn't even have whatsapp or anything
i had maybe 30-40 people who had
my phone number and  I was
always hidden behind my logos
t doesn't matter I
realized relatively early on that this isn't really
the future, that social media is
n't just kind of community
management and answering comments like that, but
that you stand with your face in
the front line and say we're
the people for  this brand stands and
if we do something wrong then
not only the company should go under but
then you should personally
suffer from it yes that was that was important because
it also makes you a
responsible person they say hey I
have to be responsible for customer service
but what if that's crap
then I should personally suffer from it yes,
but at the same time I also believe that
people don’t follow brands but the
people behind the brands, so that
these iconic CEOs constantly and
they are sometimes celebrated like rock stars
yes that they naturally
have a lot of trust in the film that  means a big
problem for every start-up is that no
customer initially trusts it  baby has new
brands on the market nobody knows that yet
and if you then stand with your face
behind it then that creates
trust yes that was my first thesis
saying that it should help I
started early in the influenza
world in Dubai then also friends  to
win and we
started blogging with them yes it is I
say when I invest in founders
one of my questions is always
we are you doing now it is going to be
considered normal and firebeazz so what
what are you doing today what yourself  sounds strange
but will be
considered normal in five years yes
because as a founder CEO you should live in the
future yes what you do today
is actually more with your
company it should be taken
care of by your team you should take care of
the future problems in
loosen your head yes what will happen in the
next three to five years and that
is the vision what you are working on now
your team that should they that that
what do you thought about three to five years ago
and I said at the time
okay that might sound
like a CEO who will now somehow become
Youtuber Youtuber but I think
in five years it will be very, very
normal that she is somehow the founder
just be followed on social
media and also be celebrated and
at the same time even if something
should go wrong you can write to them and you
can trust the company but
at the same time you should also have the
sense of responsibility that
if you mess up that you understand with your
face  so and today I have
the same principle I said what
is weird today but in five years
it will be normal and we have built content
house white Lanikai yes we
really have Creator Influenza now we
have music studies professor the
music studio with sound engineers
cameramen real content  from the
way you know it from the USA from
Youtubers where the  they all live together and they
create videos all the time it
might sound strange today
why does a car dealer do that online
but I think in five years an
online business will make a living from how well
they could create yes and that's
one of the reasons why  we will actually
still be the market leader in five years
what was what then the hacks to get such a big
account as mine of course it
helps when you have all those celebrity
friendships or also because such
gifts can be
presented over the that helps  Of course,
but I mean
you also did a raffle afterwards
when you could win that
you could visit each other and then that will
probably somehow attract the attention of the
elementary school
followers, so what do you want to
recommend to me when I'm that you with the
little 20000  in cm account on the go
what to do what to do you just have to
live a good life or  is it you know
how to block with her so first of all it's as nice as you what's the point yes I
explained that yesterday just now
but
at the time it was important for me
to call Siri or Blumenberg or
Wall Street German to get an article
I also got but
I always felt so missing, yes,
I always hoped that they would write something well
or that they would say it exactly
as I said it,
it sometimes doesn't work
and I thought to myself in this world
we should be able to talk unfiltered
directly  with the audience i have yes
and i wanted to have my own voice
thats so pretty tired so contests
i am not a big fan of them
because people never really follow you
but just wait until the decision
and then they unfollow you again
yes and  such media changes, yes, the
rules really do change every year,
sometimes every six months, what
works these days is Schu  ld
videos so this rialto there this tik
tok version and I always call it
instant gratification food megatrend
that people say people have less and
less patience you can see that in
other and business models I
just invested in a few business models
that we get started within 10 minutes
always deliver everything that's
left or right and because I
believe in two megatrends if you know
that in Dudweiler that's been around for
ages and you already know it's all active
in
Japan and Australia
and
I do a lot of
angels
100,000
at least 100,000
but also a lot  early so we are very
willing to take risks yes we do preseed and
therefore also see startup hero as there then here
is not necessarily the
lion's den for YouTube who that is
, we also made some episodes out of
it but it's actually my
investment vehicle
so
I think if  I've now answered your question
, how can you get a lot of
followers  that's already
outdated and six months ago I think
there are two megatrends these days one
thing ization something else instant
gratification that also applies to business
is that means a lot of people are moving to the
big cities yes that's urbanization
the other is he people no
longer have patience and there  also spills over to
such videos so we see
these 30 second
videos 15 to 30 second videos
within the first three seconds
ihookup that the extremely good for
Dionys gives a while video
checklist we have created our
content house and
that could  I will of course give you a few
tips on how to get followers
, but in general you
should always create more value and then
stand for something, yes, how many people work
with you in the channels, so how many
do you have full-time there now,
almost ten are okay  but who then really
like to produce for your channels,
that was a bit little
for me  e I only noticed later
or was I already active for a long time I
think he did it pretty well
and the USA he also has a different
style
Inspiration I think I let myself
be inspired by everyone’s skype I
can learn from everyone
and now also about you  now
you can look at a big can of ZDF RTL Sat1
so
that was already clean Airline to
Dubai and then your typical game
come by and then all the weapons
were the pictures you then I'm
good too so that I just had a
prime time  Show 2 hours on RTL 8:15
p.m. and it was shot entirely in
Germany and it has
n’t been signed yet, but we’re about to
get my own
show now, I won’t say which
station you wanted to hear on walk alone
don't make a
bigger
broadcast I haven't had anything to do with
it yet but can
still go
here
[music]
[laughter]
can go
to you normally  se not so yes they
are of course processes lasting weeks,
sometimes even six to nine months
and then being able to present it in such a
condensed way and then
doing it in such a way that it is entertaining and also being able to present
the core essence of the
investment procedure in such a
way is extremely good  so I think that's
very important for Germany ok which
platform is right for you so
you've even got it quickly become
YouTube I mentioned tiktok are you so
yeah I think I have over 2.6
million combined Apollo and each
channel also has a different one  target group
other recipe for success yes said to me
tiktok has now become very strong in the last
year and a half
he is for a younger group
must also have less patience
very short videos but we
too active my game yes I have now so a
week ago  about started runs well in
turkish so not that long okay
so really have to push with content
now also get a lot of followers relatively quickly
instagram is so the
basis yes you can
I believe in that nowadays
if someone says you have a
reach you are successful on
such a tired one is measured an Instagram
YouTube those are the
important channels  YouTube makes longer,
longer videos, yes, what is
successful there should not run under 10 minutes
, yes, Instagram is just extremely
only Gurlitt and as long
as that for a professional network, I have
very selective videos and content where I
then if it is really completely just
business or  a tip that
I really want to share with the professional network then it's on LinkedIn
but and Twitter are just short
thoughts but it means
you know you'll
continue to work on it until next year because you think it's
ultimately on your fires and thus
also on ellinika  deposit correctly i
believe this is an integral part
of online business i  st and will be
even more important in the next five years
, everything have you heard a bit
about the contenthouse or are you
still working on it, yes,
exactly how is the
[music]
probability
everything since we have him but also from
that of Unicorn
correct
so  I am like I said I we
are often compared to other markets
and other players
I say ultimately
evaluate and that is a decision
between a few people but what
really counts in the end is what
the buyer pays
again here at the start  our
friendly digital content agency
House of Yas Yas with y.a.s.  As is well known, the
colleagues in Cologne are
a team of 40-50 people
and they are looking for further help. There is also
a Shih dog for
me  I also like working for customers
in the socially committed area, this
includes for the Kindernothilfe or
the Federal Center for Health
Education, but also larger corporations
such as Fraport, there are all kinds of
benefits, flexible working hours, fitness
and a wide range of housing offers, so
whoever wants to be in the mood for social media  has
Cologne maybe definitely check what
House of Yas then offers a clear option
to stand there all mazion also under
House of Yas point de slash career
or otherwise of course if you are an
exciting digital content
agency so you need agency again
please think of house doctor  yes
[music]
like how how much bigger is the next
auto1 gewerbemeldea  mt because they're only 34
I don't know so the
bigger ones aren't public
yet and it's also irrelevant I think in
the end I think they've built big
companies if they become
profitable at some point then
we can talk about it
[laughter]
yes if
that  Crown Prince not only has a palace,
but
I
announced almost two years ago that I have all
my donations, so to speak, and put a lot of things into the
foundation and,
unbelievably, I received an
invitation from the Pope a few days later because then
with him  Pope at home in Rome Vatican
right at his house so he lives with
the guest
and I said then you are an
inspiration he speaks 8 languages extremely you t
lked to him I spo
e
in English but I know
here can also be German and there can also
as I said, eight more languages or they
re inspiration and I just think you c
n g
t a lot o
money from this whole capitalism  The language of
capitalism is actually mathematics,
but what you need in the world of morality
is simply the language of
love, yes, and then I said who is going
to teach us that, and then there's
actually no business that can teach you that, that
's mostly how it is
spiritual leaders and people who
just don't necessarily
focus on money and don't think if you
want to lead a really fulfilling life as an entrepreneur
you have to speak both languages mathematics and l
ve and to combine that
learned that with the conve
sations I did in  in the last two
years I have also published part of
my book, so the combination
between morality and
capitalism has
two editions, one in German
and one in English
Market yourself
then with your such media as you know
Galatians  If only 10% of your followers are
German, then you're on the road all over the world
and then you also
do media in the German market in the sense
of watching TV and something like that, exactly in
Germany I have a few things on the
subject of press or TV,
but as I said, there are 10  % of my
followers are from Germany but
there are also many people in
Germany who know me but don't
necessarily
buy them suspiciously, then that speaks for the fact that
you didn't buy them, so
now everyone has to say
[music]
[laughter]
I do that too  if I
don't like the business model, what
exactly because I think when you freeze
a few hits in your portfolio Angel
portfolio to bairoda to land an
extremely
funny story I
had invested in a company in 2015 or 16
I had completely forgotten yes, really
that was one of those  Chat app
WhatsApp
really
didn't know
anything about him
Hey somehow doesn't work I
'm doing something else now  s and the other
thing I didn't understand either yes that
was a kind of he said somehow build
a digital world with avatars like that
and I can only watch the movie my avatar
and does now want more so no that
avatar is ok no idea do
n't understand but  I'm there so that
somehow this summer
I was then in LA for 2 months. They have
now moved to LA
also shareholders so yes you are
one of the first and meanwhile
we also have 400000000 Grace and then four
billion valuation do you want
what are you actually still
doing what I tried to tell you at the time
but meanwhile it is
relatively successful
T-Base Avatar cinema birth  of and there
are just really world-
renowned in the real is called the
hot ginis ginis ginis yes you've
always been ge
NES and sit  z is in 1 l the sitters
have just bought a building with such
an office with slides inside and
huge so with your own Valais service
it runs you are generally not so
this one
so I don't understand now
produce
meanwhile and that's why
2014 at 150  €
went home and said please
invest in this bitcoin and
he says what is that yes I'm going
to put everything I have into this
thing now he's a
pensioner my age and I said why
I don't understand how that how that
works with the evaluation yes and
what produces that and that's why
I said don't do it then I did it three
years later in 2017
you still doubled my stake
but it also felt
like I didn't deserve this profit
and that's why I'm  I from that I
find he so
I have to somehow add value
so I don't have to justify in the magic
sitting in Dubai too  because not many of these
information and are on the go or is
that I think now worldwide
there is also in Dubai you know very
quickly with the regulation so they
have now also allowed some things
there is now also a blockchain center
in Dubai as I said  I
will definitely
find something at some point that is based on the blockchain
and also in companies it gives
me more economy and maybe
also an sl-class in the crypto world
that then also produces something and
then I look at it sorry, as
I said, I tend to do it  Investments in
startups tag based scalable
have now also got a release date
platform that has been cleaned up yes
the dogs have now been
managed by Softbank okay is also
quite successful as I said I
have a few
ideas where I can invest and at the
moment there are cryptocurrencies like that
Things shouldn't have to
be for German ambassadors in FRIENDS Arena
f  for Dubai as my Lascal
tells when Americans come
that you've grown a bit for me that's why you
visit again if
now it's good yes quite a lot of Germans
there was the story that they are all
back on the tax
situation but only looking at the whites was
cheaper  back again so if then this
very interesting Dubai everyone loves a lot of
soccer professionals and so we are all still
with you and will come by yes I know
many and none have withdrawn they
are all just on vacation it is too hot in
Dubai it is so I am too  5
months a year not in Dubai because in the
summer it's just too hot but
I know many people who have moved over there
and are also happy there. The sun is the
German
soul  that is then shown very
large but there are still enough
people in Germany so it's
not that many u
mmoved some made in the evening, of course, that
also has tax advantages for some and everyone
does it for different reasons, one does it
because they feel safer in the country,
the other does it because of the weather, the
others do it maybe because they
want to expand on the market and
maybe also other content  want to show
some live in both countries so
it's really always different individually of
course I didn't say for myself for
tax reasons
I'm moving to Dubai 12 years ago
I want to optimize that no money but
meanwhile it's of course great
if you have 0% income tax  but
founding start-ups in Dubai is not
cheap, so much more expensive than in
Germany
Germany is only more expensive if you are
successful then of course you pay a
lot more taxes but in
Dubai it costs a lot more to found a party
yes you just pay $10,000
License fee per year
or meanwhile there are other
types d  They have to be cheaper but when
we started what we shared expensively in
Germany at 15 € for a
business registration and then it starts of course
you have other costs but
we have plans to do so on site as
I said is still
coming you would permanently so that  is
for you the next 20-30 years as far as
you can reasonably estimate it
is always you know I as the center of my
life as Dubai as a base
is nice yes but I am also
on the road a lot so as I said 5
months I am not in  Dubai then
you are here I am in Germany USA
so Europe is missing sometimes when the
weather is nice in southern France so the
places have to say you fly
privately is your own plane or
that you the
plane doesn’t make any sense so I
fly a lot  hours I have
one
I work with a jet company
and I have a good deal there that
if you have to then
please tell me how  the ready and then
Düsseldorf exactly but well there are
also I don't always have to fly
privately e.g.  the Arabs, especially the
Gulf States, they have very, very good
airlines, so you don’t need to
name brands there,
but as I said, if e.g.
The day before yesterday I was in Berlin, Stuttgart,
Koblenz and Cologne, Mr.
I couldn't have done that, I
had brief appointments everywhere and then
you can fly that well, you
don't need to do it that
well, you can also do it by train,
but then it takes three days  but is
it like that so
lifestyle that maybe dream
or say very impressive of course it
is in essence that at white znika there has
n't been any money for you yet in the sense
you're probably already getting a
salary we also have
secondary  Events also Jan
at the same time
, of course, it's a bit
more expensive, yes, but we are also a
large group with which I always fly,
we are already 12 14 people, always eat
and then it's people
friends business
partners, yes, among other things, so everyone has
everyone  has something to do
so you don't really see
my team so much so I'm a lot of people think
what are you looking for alone in
S  Southern France or just I'm not
alone so we're already big
friends of yours or so few are
friends are also there but so
employees so my assistant
camera Cro & Security to all the people
who belong and is also German
people on what is Qatar today
seen more often now there was
also a few weeks later German
rappers but meanwhile successful what
we visited together in
Cologne he was with me
in Dubai two weeks ago
also have a music project and but that's still
top secret and because Router makes music  Yes,
I'm not a singer or dancer now,
but I would have the lockers. Yes, as I said,
I don't do it anymore. It's my
project. It also has something
to do with entrepreneurship, but that will come
out next year, so I'm looking forward to
it, as I said  you
also have to combine resources as an
entrepreneur I don't know so
many
musicians now I also have my own music studio
and
subtle could be right now
we're getting closer to the thing and that I've
only just been in contact again, e.g.  but as
I said, there are a lot of musicians from
Germany in Dubai too and then
I know many of them are just
friends like Kevin Kuranyi e.g.  the
former soccer player I was with him
yesterday the day before yesterday
I know because
Kevin Kuranyi and Patrick Owomoyela were
just playing soccer I just
picked up Kevin in Stuttgart
Soccer player
example shows I
shot the RTL show with them I know where
I was undercover
I was surprised and said hey, I'm a volunteer here,
I'd
like to play football and then
these seven-year-old and ten-year-old
Jan said something under Theresa, wait a minute,
I brought my team and
did you have all that, national
players who were of course very happy
[laughter]
went to
six different charitable organizations and then said
I would like to
volunteer and so I got
mixed up with the flixbus founders who
are really what could be that they
are then I think they are disguised like that but
that's not so funny because
I don't have that quite normally but I
had one  I have an alias and
with such a charitable organization
I have the entrance and I wanted to
present the everyday heroes
yes there is then e.g.  a lady who has been
cooking for such a youth home for 30 years
and she somehow only has 180 €
available a month for somehow 20
children and they are actually magicians
that
you don’t see and
I wanted to present the hidden champions of our society that I am one  I
said I can help out somehow
and the production company said that
is a
used car dealer who would like to
somehow
fit Sheeran somehow and then
I said they said yes he can
do an internship or have a look
, he can help out somehow then
back then and in the few days
that I was there I really saw what you
need I didn't ask her directly
I've always seen and the
poor thing she somehow only has so little
money available for the food how does
she do it  at all or there is missing on the
TV or in the workshop there are
no devices and so on and then
next day or a ta  After that
I said I'm not really so
and so I'm an entrepreneur
from Dubai and I'd
like to solve all your problems yes and that was the
show and it's so undercover and then
with such a resolution and that was
extremely emotional  because I also
saw that there is poverty in old age in Germany
I went to a
pensioners association and the lady lives
on 8 € a day yes and she worked her whole
life raised three children
and that was an
aspect  where I said these
people deserve a presence on television
Prime time were on television for 20:15 for 2
hours and that was very well received
because it wasn't about
me, I was just the ambassador in the
sense of saying hey let's
let's take a look behind the scenes who
the everyday heroes of Germany are
so
probably not all
points touched on all anecdotes central
and turning points hopefully yes
cut and so I will
definitely continue to follow how the
company developed into Annika
Germany by the way is not an issue for
you a German is not an issue for us
first of all most of us
do not like Focus white sneakers because of the
competition simply because there
are other priorities now  there are other
countries first
ok so stay tuned there
and I'll be happy if you're up to it
I'll have someone organize everything in May haeberlen in
the festival
let's see how we log you in with your caretaker if in doubt we'll
find ways and means and maybe
there's yes  also an update podcast
with mum watching something from the witch book and
then when the percentage career
starts with Qatar there will be a lot to
offer hopefully a lot a
lot thanks Laras is happy to thank you very much see you
next time ciao ciao
[music]
at the end a note  a
kind of germ cell of OMR many things
started at an event called
On  line Marketing Camp that I did
together with the Hamburg Media
School 2018 It started at 9 a.m. Always
around 20-30 people who were interested in the topic
who wanted to immerse themselves in three and a half
days
who knew a wide variety of online marketing
wanted to build up in this network
the packs  and wanted to understand the basics
who got there and were
mostly quite enthusiastic that you
then started to develop more from it
, at least the whole topic of
online marketing camp is there today
and I think it will continue to be very appreciated
soon it will start again in life
there we have it  Good from November 3rd to 6th
, so value yourself Burkhardt or
means at Team Team in the company
and a person that would be something for
that person or
people in the circle of friends testable what
is there at Hamburg Media School dot
com Slash further education  with the code
umr-10 there is also a 10% discount on
this offer all information again  at
our at Hamburg again
[music]
this podcast is produced by
popstars
at MR